we've heard of a push-pull right well
it's used to get the answers do you want
by the way you frame the questions an
absurd new push poll from The Associated
Press purports define 57% of Americans
think President Trump is a racist that
includes more than 8 out of 10 African
Americans nearly three-quarters of
Hispanics and nearly 50% of whites
let's bring in someone knows a little
bit about media manipulation former
Republican presidential candidate Herman
Cain and radio talk show host garland
Nixon haven't seen both of you and way
too long all right let's get let's get
to this Garland let's start with you
okay um first of all I think if that if
the poll is true it's highly depressing
to me okay so that's number one but
given the fact that the economy really
is doing better we have the lowest black
unemployment in 17 years
lots of good indicators slightly higher
graduation rate from high school which
is good but he's been in office for 13
months people's wages will start going
up and we could bring these jobs back
and so forth you know what's not to love
yeah but that doesn't address the issue
here at hand in this poll is Donald
Trump a racist and personally I would
say that that term is far too
restrictive for a guy who's exhibited
the level of bigotry as Donald Trump I
think we have to use a broader term I
think bigotry works here's a guy we all
remember the insults to the handicapped
with the new york times guy he said that
a Mexican judge was unable to dispense
their duties simply because they thought
it was a conflict no no I know it came
out that way but i I've known him for 13
years I don't tolerate racism don't like
racism wouldn't be friends with someone
who's a racist so I actually know him
he's not a racist I'm just telling you
it's factually untrue to say he's a
racist because I know him that's the
only excuse you can say I know him I
know I've looked into his soul or
something like that no I just go by what
he says as the tune of the famous coach
said you are what your record says you
are i Herman okay you heard garland says
you know he's a he's a racist bigoted
bigoted it's not all encompassing go
ahead
now mr. Nixon please don't try to talk
over me which is what
liberals do he is not a racist and that
you and others are concluding that he's
a racist based upon your speculation
from some statements that were made you
have no evidence no results that
suggests that he's a racist secondly I
like Laura I know mr. Trump I can spot
racism 3,000 miles away and he doesn't
have a racist bone in his body based
upon my own personal experience but in
that particular study that you're
referencing every incident identified is
based upon speculating that he must have
been saying something racist when in
fact he was not saying anything racist
or Republicans it's 21% of Republicans
viki's racist according to this poll
what's shocking Democrats 85% Herman
what do you believe that 21% of
Republicans think Donald Trump is racist
I mean I don't know who these
Republicans are but I don't know if they
belong well you can party I mean it's
crazy
that's fire station tweet as much
exactly disagree with the policies yes
but you can't disagree with the results
here's why you have such a high number
of Democrats believing that he's racist
and you have a few Republicans they are
being told this the liberal media and
many Democrats have been using this
false racist narrative ever since this
president became president and even
before and as a result many of them are
simply repeating what they have been
told this president is not racist
Garland one of the things that I think
has has perhaps stalled the advancement
of African Americans in this new study
that we don't have time to get into but
his economic Institute report about
wages and an unemployment from 1968 to
2017 is that we have tolerated millions
of people coming into America who take
jobs that working poor middle-class
people coming into the workplace for the
first time
used to have and a lot of those jobs are
gone now there's those entry-level jobs
hurt like a lot of people that I came
from and a lot of minorities
and they're not there anymore so here's
what I would say the people and Trump is
standing against I would say that most
of the black people in the community
would disagree with you for this reason
and that is black people are not looking
for jobs picking grapes they're not
looking for jobs working in hotels they
want to be lawyers and doctors and
policemen fruit and did paper suits and
I worked in restaurants you never did
those jobs those jobs taught me a lot
but so black Americans want the same
jobs as everyone else they're not but
the black community is not blaming the
guy at the bottom they're blaming the
people who make the decisions that guy
we're climbing in globalists who want to
keep wages low for Americans I'm not
blaming those I'm blaming that people
want to keep the wages point is that if
anyone who is convinced by someone who
has more money than they do that the
people that have less money than they do
are the problem are being manipulated
Carmen last word real quick the
manipulation is going on by liberals and
Democrats I see it every day I hear it
every day on my radio show and by the
way mr. Nixon I'm part of the black
community I'm a radio talk show host
I like that job I never dreamed that I
would be able to achieve that job but
you want to know how I got it I worked
hard at it I got it the old-fashioned
way probably the way you got you'll sew
these blanket statements about people
not making a lot of money being told
something about somebody that makes a
lot of money those are irrelevant
comparisons all right guys great segment